one of Humanity's biggest obsessions is
trying to figure out how cities are
going to look like in the future by the
year 2050 68 of the world's population
is projected to live in urban areas but
most cities are not prepare for this we
have congestion crime a housing crisis
and just an endless array of problems
that come up when you try to pack a
massive amount of people in a small
footprint science fiction envisions a
world that's adapted to these conditions
through technology these problems have
either been eradicated or worsened and
some sci-fi has been way off but some
has been kind of spot on but either way
they've pushed the boundaries in our
thinking and they've given us a glimpse
into the future in how we could be
living how we could be interacting with
our environments and with each other
so today I want to look at three Sci-Fi
movies with really interesting City
Concepts and break them down from a
design and urban planning point of view
this video is sponsored and brainstormed
with millinote more on them later in
this video
[Music]
based on a future where crime level has
gotten so bad that it's gone into a
Perpetual state of Martial law the
police have dual function as judges so
they can give you a sentence on the spot
including the death penalty the setting
Mega City one is a giant megalopolis
that spans most of eastern U.S and some
of Canada which by the way is really
close to the east coast Mega region in
real life and the architecture of the
city actually acts as a form of
surveillance in controlling the people
people live in these really dense
residential towers with these nice big
atriums but when there's a crime in the
building it automatically triggers A
system that locks you in and keeps you
contained in the building the real
building Ponta Tower which is a
residential Tower near Johannesburg that
tower has Eerie parallels to the one in
the movie when it was first built in the
70s it was a really desirable address
but it very quickly turned into a slum
it was hijacked by gangs at some point
and now it's like a symbol for crime and
Urban Decay in the city the decline was
largely due to the social and political
conditions at the time but
architecturally speaking it's brutalist
you know there's a lot of similarities
with a panopticon concept which is the
Universal Design concept for prisons and
I think it's this imposing architecture
that turned this building into a symbol
of Decay you know architecture is not
just for living in or working in it's
also a symbol and the movie actually
uses these towers as a symbol of order
and surveillance like a lot of real City
designs
one of the best examples would be this
guy his ideas for cities inspired a lot
of developments throughout the world and
it's had a huge impact on how cities are
designed today in 1920s liquobicier
created several City plans to heal Paris
from its problems it was congested it
was dirty it was deteriorating and his
solution was to raise the entire city
and replace it with this he believed
this would create order and Harmony by
separating all of the different
functions within a city like industrial
commercial residential recreational and
all the different traffic arteries they
would all be set up in different zones
open space was a priority for air
circulation because it was so lacking in
Paris so he designed these blocks to
have tons of open space and circulation
Space by packing more density into a
smaller footprint this was never really
implemented in Paris thank God but many
housing projects throughout the world
took this approach and they actually
became kind of awful places to live if
you separate all of these functions you
get dead zones throughout the day you go
to work during the day you come back
home during the evening and if you have
to work late walking in this office area
becomes kind of dangerous because the
streets are dead same with the
residential areas During certain hours
there's like nobody on the streets all
the activity like restaurants or bars
that would be openly are in a separate
Zone and that's why well-designed cities
there's a mixture of different uses
there's shops restaurants offices and
apartments so you can get a constant
flow of activity and eyes on the streets
cities and neighborhoods become a lot
safer and more lively when you have this
kind of organic surveillance but in
corbusier's designs this was never
really considered which created really
unsafe areas and the need for constant
surveillance so in a future where crime
rate is through the roof it's not really
an accident that they use this type of
City design in this movie
whenever I make a video like this it
takes up a lot of research and
brainstorming and up until recently we
used to collect all the research in a
document but it started to get kind of
limited so when Milano reached out to be
honest I hadn't heard of them before so
I wanted to make sure I tried it out for
a bit before I shared it with you guys
so we tried brainstorming on this idea
board and we actually use this to guide
the entire research for this video and
we really liked it just having a visual
board makes everything super clear and
it kind of allowed us to make
connections that we didn't really see
before they have really nice templates
for different types of work from
research mood board and storyboard and
once we had a rough idea of which movies
we wanted to talk about we could drag
and drop different notes and links and
the best thing is that it actually
converts the links into thumbnails so
you don't need to download anything to
put on your board all of this is on the
cloud and you can share with other
people millennial is free with no time
limit so you can sign up using the link
in the description and start your next
creative project I'm actually really
curious how you guys use melanose so if
you liked it just let me know in the
comments
[Music]
the movie The Fifth Element depicts a
mega City that solved the population
crisis by building vertically these
towers go on for miles and miles and
miles and they use flying cars and
public transit navigating in three
dimensions to get around natural light
and ventilation is an issue and the
further you go down it gets worse and
worse even above it's not really the
nicest conditions people live in these
little pods with like little to no
personalization building vertically
makes a lot of sense especially if it's
a city with a clear perimeter there's a
lot of efficiencies when your
infrastructure can serve more people in
a smaller footprint there's a couple of
technologies that would have to involve
to make this scenario plausible you
would need flying cars or some sort of
vertical Transportation which is
actually not that far-fetched there are
already testing these automated taxi
drones we would also need new materials
and new construction technology like for
example there's this new type of Bio
concrete that can heal its own cracks
there's also been a lot of development
in heavy Timber construction for example
we have the tallest wood tower being
built in Japan which is obviously huge
because you can offset a lot of the
carbon footprint I think more than the
material strength it's the
constructability that's going to be a
bigger issue how do you get materials
that high it's fine when it's like 30 or
40 stories but when it goes up to like
100 Stories the concrete starts to
harden and that's problematic
you know Burj Khalifa the tallest
building in the world they created a
special mixture that can travel in
liquid form over a long distance and
they're going to keep coming up with
these new solutions for these new
challenges but maybe the construction
doesn't even happen at ground level
maybe it starts at an intermediate level
that acts as another ground plane in
fact you can see a lot of bridges
connecting different buildings if you
want to go from here to here it doesn't
really make sense for you to have to go
all the way down to get to another
building and we actually do have cities
mostly cold or Windy Cities like
Minneapolis or Calgary that have smaller
versions of these Bridges and they're
called skyways people Park their cars
they go to work they go shopping and
they can do all of this without going
outside one of the reasons I moved away
from Toronto was because of the cold so
I really truly appreciate these internal
pathways but it's kind of a problem
because not everyone gets to use them
these skyways are privately owned
because they connect private buildings
so the developers don't really have an
incentive to make them more welcoming in
fact when the City of Minneapolis hired
architectural Consultants to improve the
accessibility to the skyways most of the
developers response was that they don't
really want to attract the wrong kind of
people in an entire city that's
connected with skyways it really makes
me wonder where is the line between
public and private
we'll talk about the constructability
again for a sec a lot of people think
that the problem with tall buildings is
the weight of the building but actually
the bigger issue is the force of the
Wind on the building we call this the
lateral Force basically the higher you
go the stronger the wind force is going
to be on the building like if you have a
wind force of 10 kilometers an hour at
the bottom of the building it can go up
to like 70 or 80 on top and apparently
at the top of the Burj Khalifa It's like
200 kilometers an hour and it's also
really unpredictable a common concept
when it comes to tall buildings is
torquing not twerking twerking it's like
twisting one of the solutions is
exterior bracing it holds the building
in place and it stops it from twisting a
lot of these buildings will probably
look more like this another solution is
the original concept is from Frank Lloyd
Wright and it's mile high tower it's
dense at the bottom and it tapers at the
top when it was Bill filter was pretty
revolutionary but now you have the Burj
Khalifa and other skyscrapers using the
same concept but the problem with this
is that you need to make the bottom so
fat to get a smaller top and it's just
not really economical to drop off so
much mass at the top so one of the new
Solutions is by calatrava in Dubai and
it's gonna be the tallest tower in the
world and I think it's kind of Genius
instead of bracing it or bundling it
they've got cables attached throughout
the building to hold it when it sways so
for example when the building wants this
way this way it'll have cables pulling
from this side and if the building wants
to sway this way it'll have cables
pulling from this side by the way if you
guys want more information on these
structural kits I'll leave the link in
the description I mean just a couple
hundred years ago people would have
never thought of skyscrapers you know we
only started getting these since the
invention of elevators so probably in
the future with new materials and new
technology we're probably going to be
able to get like 500 stories or a
thousand stories I think the bigger
problem is going to be how can we create
Equitable spaces throughout you know
like I said there's this blurring of the
private and public spaces but also
having this height naturally creates the
really desirable spaces at the top at
the really undesirable sections at the
bottom we would need artificial lighting
that really closely mimics daylight and
also a way to provide fresh air for the
lower areas but also just making sure
that we have the right policies in place
to not create these social divides
between these sections
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't really matter how tall you
can build if there isn't a way to move
around efficiently minority of poor has
a much more comprehensive vision of how
a city could completely reshape itself
based on this new transportation system
instead of flying cars they have these
maglev pots that travel on these
dedicated Lanes which are integrated
into the urban Fabric and they even
become a part of the building's facade
the design of these is actually really
cool it's got an internal gyroscope so
that you can stay upright whether you're
traveling horizontally or vertically
it's self-driving it's controlled by a
centralized AI so if you trust the
government you just hop in put in your
destination and boom you're there it
takes out the human error Factor so
there's less chances of collisions and
they can maneuver in a way that can
solve a lot of these congestion issues
now this type of infrastructure is kind
of a similar idea to the one in Fifth
Element but the biggest difference is
that you can go straight from your
destination to your apartment and you
don't need to go outside at all and I
think that would change the social
dynamics in so many ways there's a kind
of forced social interaction that
happens just by the fact that you live
close to someone and you run into each
other in lobbies or in the elevators and
if these lobbies or amenity spaces are
designed in a way that encourages social
interaction then you get to know your
neighbors so even if you don't have any
friends or family at least you have the
people around you that you can interact
with that's the traditional idea of a
community and having neighbors with more
and more Towers being built this idea of
community has been slowly and slowly
disintegrating which adds to the social
isolation but maybe a system like this
could actually democratize buildings
these days we have a lot of Sky Gardens
and amenity spaces within buildings but
they can only be used through the
building so by having the ability to
access the building from different
points maybe some of these spaces could
be made accessible to the public or to
paid members through an app all of this
is really exciting but who knows maybe
in the future our built environments are
just going to be secondary and we're
going to be spending more time in the
virtual reality or maybe cities become
co-organisms to protect against Natural
Disasters or threat of war or maybe we
just stopped trying to improve the city
altogether Mark Wiggly once said
architecture never derived its force
from stability of culture but rather
from the expression of those moments
when the sense of stability slipped if
we can agree on one thing I think it's
that we're living in really uncertain
times and this is the breeding ground
for a lot of the changes in the
environment there's a lot to unpack here
so let me know what you think in the
comments and if you want to know more
about architecture I'm going to leave a
playlist at the end of this and if you
like sci-fi or dystopian architecture
you should probably have a look at my
neon and Burning Man videos don't forget
to like And subscribe and I'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]